[Music]
that's my new neighbor what is his name
captain funtastic that's what I've been
calling him such a nice day for a jog
[Music]
what my ass isn't a glutinous skirt
given the current climate it feels
inappropriate for me to comment on your
Bob Todd is the snare drum you could
bounce a quarter off that thing screw
him
today's my day I'll make it partner baby
headline news somebody in this room is
about to be summit worldwide sports
management smart the sockets oh [ __ ]
your mom ad agency exec oh no it's my
brother said you're gonna [ __ ] your
brother's ma they say that I don't
connect with men I hired a psychic
Facebook I can help you why don't we
have some team this smells like dirt oh
that's just jasmine tea if you don't
count the weed no peyote no crack
[Music]
I feel weird after last night yeah
that's what happens when tequila meets
desperation stop doing are you reading
my mind because if you can hear my inner
thoughts I am super
does he mess me up did you [ __ ] yourself
no no no I have psychic powers you can
hear what I'm thinking right now not you
just me you know you could use this to
your advantage right
I'm bluffing these false pretzels are
delicious I'm gonna freeze my smart
mahat baby ice cubes
[Music]
and shot look at you pressing all the
ladies whatever why would I waste a
second owner when I got you standing
right here in front of me why our eyes
always closed ugly damn eyes open but
she look crazy as hell
[Music]
who you I hope it's okay I borrowed your
mask
welcome to Wakanda close your mouth
don't breathe don't sing
[Music]
you